[Musique]
deux ans après sa disparition les
cendres du poète réunionnais boris
gamaleya ont été rapatriés lundi dans
son île natale un hommage de dix jours
est rendu à l'artiste avec des
expositions
j'ai pris cette initiative dans l'appli
de vos risques et malia qui est mon ami
d'enfance
marc informé du souhait de son père que
ces cendres rejoignent la réunion donc
nous avons un peu partagé des choses et
moi je me suis dis pas dix jours il faut
au moins dix jours pour fêter ce grand
poète à l'occasion du retour des cendres
donc cette décade c'est l'occasion pour
la réunion de se réapproprier
le poète boris gamaleya ce site à la
bibliothèque départementale que s'est
ouverte ce mardi 21 septembre la décade
en l'honneur de ce poète qui a marqué la
réunion
débarquement
à travers
bibliothèque départementale
est quand même dans la démarche de la
transmission
culturel et boris gamaleya
le célèbre à travers fait bécade
une émotion difficile à contenir pour sa
fille aînée
je suis une énorme émotion après avoir
entendu
ces institutions se sont engagés pour le
sait les français
j'en ai mes larmes aux yeux enfin bon
c'est tellement
depuis la création par l'académie de la
réunion du prix littéraire boris
gamaleya des collèges 2018 les prix sont
remis aux lauréats fin juin cette année
il a été choisi d'inclure cette
manifestation au sein de la décade
brusque maleya et est un auteur qui ce
qui doit être connue des jeunes
réunionnais et des collégiens et ce
concours est l'occasion
de laisser ces jeunes s'exprimer nous
avons devoir d'ouvrir cet espace de
parole de texteurs de poésie
pour que de sam de mon coeur pour que
ces deux jeunes réunionnais s'exprime
dans l' identité leur culture leur
histoire leur vécu et surtout leurs
espoirs le programme complet de la
décade de boris gamaleya est disponible
au
www.bourse.lu ya point est re
[Musique]